in 2023 kotzgesant has existed for 10
years insanely long in Internet years
we're among the largest sciency channels
on YouTube and still a bit of a black
box to people so let's talk about
ourselves a bit in three parts our
backstory how we Finance our work and
the values of kotskazat let's jump back
to a more innocent time from humble
beginnings to today
kuzuk's Foundation was laid when Philip
our founder dropped out of high school
as a teenager
learning seemed Daft and useless and he
wasn't interested in anything until a
very special teacher at a school for
dropouts grabbed him by the neck the way
she taught was different
she talked about Connections and the big
picture she told a story for the first
time ever Philip wanted to learn more
without being forced it was a key life
experience
courtskazat tries to recreate this
experience for you nothing is boring if
you tell a good story and we try to tell
these stories to spark excitement and
make you want to go on and learn more
because of the one teacher that could do
this Philip got a high school degree
studied history and design and
eventually started kotzkazat as a
passion project inspired by crash course
world history in 2012 YouTube was less
commercial and more idealistic you could
make a living with videos as involved as
ours and that was fine the goal was
creative freedom and so for the first
few years it actually cost money to make
korskazat we had no outside funding just
intrinsic motivation and a few friends
from University we worked for clients
during the day and on courtskazat at
night 80 to 100 hours a week it was a
real struggle but also very rewarding
but then patreon launched sponsorship
started our views increased YouTube
changed in 2015 the channel began to
break even and then to earn a profit
but we were pretty burned out at this
point so we decided to bring in more
friends and hire the first team members
full-time creating a legal entity more
people meant that we could stop
overworking do more and improve but we
also needed to earn more the livelihood
of real humans depended upon it none of
us had any experience in running a
company we didn't plan to become big or
to grow it sort of just happened a
decade later quartz gazarks is not a
small project anymore
we are an animation studio with officers
in Munich and Berlin we need computers
monitors tablets desks coffee contracts
pay licenses taxes rent and insurance
in 2023 our team consists of over 60
employees and a lot of Freelancers
around the world
Santa is alone cost millions of dollars
a year just to stay around this creates
an interesting problem with such high
production costs how can we publish our
work for free
how we Finance course out we've added up
our earnings from 2015 through 2022 our
sources of funding change depending on
opportunities and the state of the world
early on agency work was our main source
of income ad Revenue varies in some
years we got more sponsorships than in
others the shop didn't exist for a long
time then it became pretty big after we
launched our calendar
62 percent of our Revenue comes
indirectly or directly from you you
watch our videos with ads support us on
patreon or buy from our shop
the single biggest source of income by
far is our shop that alone accounted for
forty percent over the last eight years
the shops started small but once we
published our calendar for the first
time in 2016 we realized it could really
help us do more things and we started
producing more and more science products
from our posters to our gratitude
journal or Universe scented candles
YouTube ads accounted for 13 and patreon
nine percent so without your support we
would cease to exist
our shop and patreon are our most
important sources of revenue and because
we see ourselves as science
communicators we don't just do merge but
sciency products that we spend hundreds
of hours researching discussing with
experts polishing up and working on
directly with the manufacturers
they are part of the science story we
try to tell
it also just feels good to get directly
funded by you guys and give you
something back for it on top of our
videos YouTube ads are a crucial part of
our funding as well but they are not
within our control
then there's paid agency work which we
stopped doing in 2022 it accounted for
nine percent of our Revenue over the
last eight years a lot in the beginning
not much by the end then there are
commercial sponsors advertising products
they accounted for 12 of our Revenue we
also got about seven percent from German
public broadcasting for the German
Channel but ended this partnership in
finally there are institutional sponsors
representing about 10 percent
some people take issue with this
especially Bill Gates has come under
public scrutiny and we've been
criticized for even working with
organizations funded by him so let's
look at this 10 in more detail
about three percent of our Revenue over
the last eight years came from the gates
organizations for a wide variety of
topics often suggested by us
five percent comes from open
philanthropy and is only used for
specific projects with these funds we've
started Arabic Hindi Korean Japanese
Portuguese and French channels bringing
more free science content to more people
then there's a two-year funding for
original Tick Tock content which gives
us freedom to explore and learn how to
do short form science communication
the final two percent came from other
organizations like the Red Cross or the
UN for example
we choose institutional sponsors
carefully but if organizations want to
fund videos that help us spread quality
information about relevant topics this
is an easy yes for us if we have the
capacity for it on top of that the
institutional sponsors we're working
with align with our values
we have contracts with every Grant Giver
or sponsor that bars them from editorial
influence other than suggesting topic
areas like Global health or climate
change
we agree on video topics together but
sponsors can neither influence details
nor our conclusions the final decision
always remains with us and usually we
develop the topics of the videos
autonomously and tell the sponsor what
we're doing afterwards if you're
interested in how we research our videos
in detail our head of research wrote an
article about it running an educational
YouTube channel is a balancing act that
we take very seriously we're doing our
best to maintain this balance adjusting
whenever necessary as a team and a
company we want to grow to give more
people access to a science-based outlook
on the world this brings us to our final
topic why are we doing
our values and our vision
our core mission is to spark curiosity
we want to make science and humanism
accessible for as many people as
possible
the effort we put into creating our
videos is a way of achieving that our
videos are beautiful because that helps
to spark curiosity to understand complex
topics and because it just feels good to
create and watch
our research is as intensive as it is so
our videos are a good simplification of
very complicated topics
we want to make people excited about
science so they ReDiscover subjects they
hated in school and see how amazing they
are on top of curiosity we want to
inspire long-term thinking and a
positive constructive Outlook
being optimistic about the future of
humanity is not mainstream and we think
this is horrible pessimism often sounds
smart and gets more views while optimism
can sound naive but this is a bias
that's not helpful for us as a species
suit despite the gloominess of many
topics we want to approach them with
informed and well researched to optimism
not brushing Humanity's very real
challenges aside but also not falling
into the Trap of pessimism we want to
inspire you to dream a little about the
Glorious future that we could actually
build but only if we believe it's
possible in the long run we don't only
want to do this on YouTube
the idea is for kotskazak to be a
positive influence across more media on
our Tick Tock channel in the long form
content we're exploring in apps in the
VR game that will be released later this
year and the games we plan to make in
the future our shop is a central part of
this Vision we start our stories with a
video and end them with a poster there
are so many things we want to do and
thanks to you watching this right now we
have the freedom to work to the best of
our knowledge and ability in the end we
hope you like what we offer and that
we'll be doing something worthwhile for
as long as we exist and hopefully we'll
have a lasting impact by making science
and learning more fun for as many people
as possible
if you personally want to help us do
this you can watch and share our videos
check out our shop become a patreon or
give us an ad blocker exception We Exist
because of you and you have no idea how
much we appreciate that you're here and
hopefully we're less of a black box now
in any case doing courts aren't for a
decade has been a pretty crazy ride and
so from the whole team thank you so much
for being with us all these years
[Music]
wait